I got a call I was I was going to an
appointment and meeting my sister and I
saw my sister and she said you have to
go home I have chills even talking about
it instantly I knew something was wrong
I didn't quite pinpoint it yet because
Lisa was supposed to come home that day
he was going out on tour
and I raced back home and I think I ran
every red light there was trying to get
to my house and um the phone was ringing
and it kept ringing and it kept ringing
and it's in one of those horror movies
where you're trying to get the key into
the door and you can't your hands are
shaking so badly that you can't find the
hole to get the key in and and uh
praying that the phone doesn't stop
ringing and I get to the to the phone
and it's um Joe Esposito
and I will never forget this and he says
to me you know
um Cilla and I go what and it seemed
like it was forever you know for him to
tell me and I'm going what and he goes
it's Elvis and I mean I knew I knew
right then and there that something
horrible had happened and then when he
told me that he was dead
it was like
waking up from a a nightmare and hoping
to wake up from a nightmare and saying
this is a joke and I broke down and I
just I I couldn't believe it I dropped
the phone and I
I just couldn't you know believe that
that he died and I had such mixed
emotions Lisa was at the house at the
time which for a nine-year-old what a
devastating thing to go through right
she was um actually out on the golf cart
driving around with her friend and I
remember looking out the window
and thinking
well is that normal is that something
that
I have to be concerned about is you know
seeing her with her friend and just
driving all over and then I realized you
know that was her way of escaping
because the house
was filled with such mourning such
disbelief I had my own golf cart that my
father gave me and it might the key with
a tag with my name on it it's worn out
completely and it was kind of my
um key to Terror Freedom that key was my
life and I had such mixed emotions I
remember being on the playing his
playing going back to Memphis and
feeling such anger you know feeling so
many emotions of how could you do this
you know
how could you do this how could you
leave us how could you you promised you
know it's just something you never feel
that was ever going to happen to him he
he just never
felt it and hearing his father literally
howling you know for his son I can't
even describe I can't even go to where
it took me again it was
it's like walking in a
a maze by yourself and in disbelief and
feeling this spiral of going downward
and never feeling you could come out of
it because Elvis was always there
you just never thought that was going to
happen he was so young 42 years old and
I think that's the other thing that you
you look at you realize how young he was
to leave us
you know and I think that was the day
the whole world mourned
there was such a
an emptiness I think I felt for for
months after that
[Music]